I have had to do plenty of unpopular
things I think anytime you have to run a
company that endures a century and has
to endure another Century you will do
unpopular things you have no choice and
I often felt I had to sacrifice things
for the long term and whether that would
have been you know really difficult
things like you know job changes or
reductions or whether it would be things
like hey you know we're going to change
the way we do our semiconductors and a
whole different philosophy
you have no choice I mean and in times
of Crisis as well you got to be I wish
that it's not a popularity contest
the following is a conversation with
Jeannie vermetti who was a longtime CEO
president and chairman of IBM and for
many years she was widely considered to
be one of the most powerful women in the
world
she's the author of a new book on power
leadership and her life story called
good power coming out on March 7th
she is an incredible leader and human
being both fearless and compassionate it
was a huge honor and pleasure for me to
sit down and have this chat with her
this is the Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's Jeannie rometty
you worked at IBM for over 40 years
starting as a systems engineer and you
ran the company as chairman president
CEO from 2011 to 2020 IBM is one of the
largest tech companies in the world with
maybe you can correct me on this with
with about 280 000 employees
what are the biggest challenges running
the company of that size let's start
with us at a big overview question the
biggest challenges I think are not in
running them it's in changing them
and that idea to know what you should
change and what you should not change
actually people don't always ask that
question what should endure even if it
has to be modernized but what should
endure and then I found the hardest part
was changing how work got done it's such
a big company what was the parts that
you thought should endure the core of
the company that was beautiful and
powerful and could persist through time
that it should persist through time I'd
be interested do you have a perception
of what you think it would be
do I have a perception well I'm a
romantic for a history of long-running
companies so there's kind of a a
tradition as a AI person to me IBM has
some epic sort of research
accomplishments yes where you show off
you know uh deep blue and Watson just
impressive big moonshot challenges and
accomplishing those but that's I think
that's probably a small part of what IBM
is it's that's mostly like the the sexy
public facing part yeah no it is well
certainly the research part itself right
is over three thousand so it's not that
small that's a pretty big research yes
but the part that should endure ends up
being you know company that does things
that are essential to the world meaning
um
the who you know think back you said
you're romantic it was the 30s the
social security system it was putting
the man on the moon it was you know to
this day Banks don't run you know
railroads don't run uh
that is at its core it's doing Mission
critical work and so that part I think
is at its core it's a business to
business company
and at its course about doing things
that are really important to the world
be coming running and being better
running the infrastructure of the world
so doing it at scale doing it reliably
yes secure in this world that's like
everything and in fact when I started I
almost felt people were looking for what
that was and together we sort of in a
word was to be essential and the reason
I loved that word was I can't call
myself essential you have to determine I
am right so it was to be essential even
though some of what we did is exactly
what you said it's below the surface so
many people because people say to me
what does IBM do now right and over the
years it's changed so much and today
it's really a software and consulting
company consulting's a third of it and
the software is all hybrid cloud and AI
that would not have been true as you
well know back even two decades ago
right so
um it changes but I think at its core
it's that be essential you said moonshot
can all be moonshots because moonshots
don't always work but Mission critical
work so so
given the size though
when you started running it did you feel
the sort of thing that people usually
associate with size which is bureaucracy
and maybe the aspect of size a hinder
progress or hinder pivoting did you feel
that you would
um for lots of reasons I think when
you're a big company
sometimes people think of processes the
client themselves or the you know I
always say to people your process is not
your customer there is a real customer
here that you exist for and that's
really easy to fall into because they're
you know people are a master or to this
process and that's not right and when
you're big the other thing and boy
there's a premium on it is speed right
that in our industry you got to be fast
and go back like when I took over and it
was 2012.
you know we had a lot of catching up to
do and a lot of things to do and it was
moving so fast and as you well know all
those Trends were happening at once
which made them go even faster and so
pretty unprecedented actually for that
many Trends to be at one time and I used
to say to people go faster go faster go
faster and honestly
I've tired them out I mean it kind of
dawned on me that when you're that big
yeah that's a really valuable lesson and
it taught me like the house perhaps more
important than the what because
if I didn't do something to change how
work was done like change those
processes or you know give them new
tools help them with skills
they couldn't they're just like do the
same thing faster if someone tells you
you know you've got hiking boots and
they're like no go run a marathon you're
like I can't do it in those boots but so
you've got to do something and at first
I think the ways for big companies I
would call them like blunt clubs you do
what everyone does you reduce layers
because if you reduce layers decisions
go faster there's just it's math if
there's less decision points things go
faster
um you do the blunt Club thing and then
after that though it did lead me down a
you know a long journey of they sound
like buzzwords but if you really do them
at scale they're hard around things like
agile
and um because you've really got to
change the way work gets done and we
ended up training God hundreds of
thousands of people on that stuff change
it correctly on how to do it correctly
that's right versus because everybody
talks about it but the idea that you
would really have small
multi-disciplinary teams work from the
outside in set those sort of interim
steps you know take the feedback pivot
and then do it on not just products do
it on lots of things was it's a hard to
do at scale
um people always say oh I got this agile
group over here 40 people but not when
you're a couple hundred thousand people
you gotta get a lot of people to work
that way the blunt Club thing you're
talking about so flatten the
organization as much as possible yeah
yeah I probably reduce the layers of
management by half and so it that does
that has lots of benefits right time to
a decision
um more autonomy to people because and
then the idea of like faster Clarity of
of where you're going because you're not
just filtered through so many different
layers and I think it's the kind of
thing a lot of companies if you're big
have to just keep going through it's
kind of like Grass Grows you know it
just comes back and you gotta go back
down and uh and work on it so it's a
natural thing
um but I hear so many people talk about
it like this idea of like okay well who
makes a decision you've often heard
nobody can say yes and everybody can say
no and that's actually what you're
trying to get out of a system like that
so
I mean your book in general the way you
lead is very much about we and us you
know the the power of we but is there
times when a leader has to step in and
be almost autocratic take control make
hard unpopular decisions oh I am sure
you know the answer to that and and it
is of course yes
yeah you know because I actually
um a there's a leader for a time but
then there's a leader for a situation
right and so I've had to do plenty of
unpopular things I think anytime you
have to run a company that endures a
century and has to endure another
Century you will do unpopular things you
have no choice and I often felt I had to
sacrifice things for the long term and
whether that would have been you know
really difficult things like you know
job changes or reductions or whether it
would be things like hey you know we're
going to change the way we do our
semiconductors and a whole different
philosophy
you have no choice I mean and in times
of Crisis as well you got to be I wish
that it's not a popularity contest so
that's none of these jobs or popularity
contests I don't care if your company's
got one person or half a million they're
not popularity contests but
psychologically is it difficult to to
just sort of step in as a new CEO and
to do because you're fighting against
tradition against all these people that
act like Experts of their thing and they
are experts of their thing to step in
and say we need to do differently when
you had to change a company
it's really tempting to say throw
everything else out back to that what
must endure right yeah but I know when I
took over to start I knew how much he
had to change more I got into it I could
see
wow a lot more had to change right
because we needed a platform we'd always
done our best when we had a platform a
technology platform you will go back in
time and you'll think of the Mainframe
systems you'll think of the PC You'll
Think of perhaps middleware you know you
could even call services a platform we
needed a platform the next platform here
to be there
um skills when I took over if I we
inventored who had modern skills for the
future it was two out of 10 people for
the future not that they didn't have
relevant skills today but for the Future
2 out of ten yikes that's a big problem
right
um the the speed at which things were
getting done that has to so you got so
much to do and you say is that um is
that a scary thing yes do you have to
sometimes dictate yes but I did find and
it is worth it I know every big company
I know my good friend that runs General
Motors is she's had to change go back to
what is
them them you know and when you do that
that back to be essential we kind of
started with hey it's be essential then
the next thing I did with the team was
say okay now this means New Era of
computing new buyers are out there and
eh we better have new skills okay now
the next thing how do you operationalize
it and it just takes some time but you
can engineer that and get get people to
build belief and for the skills though
that means uh that means hiring and it
means training you yes yeah oh boy
that's a long skills is a really long
Topic in and of itself I try to put my
view in it I learned a lot and I changed
my view on this a lot
um
I'll go back at my very beginning say 40
years ago I I would have said
at that point okay I was always in a
hurry of I was interviewing to hire
people I don't know how you hire people
40 years ago I'd be like okay I gotta
fit in these interviews I gotta hire
someone to get this done okay then time
would go on I'm like oh that's not very
good in fact someone once said to me hey
hire the best people to work for you and
your job gets a lot easier okay I should
spend more time on this topic I spend
more time on it then it was like okay
hire experts okay okay I hired a lot of
experts over my life
and then I was really like an epiphany
and it really happened over my tenure
running the company and having to change
skills
if someone's an expert at something and
has just done that for 30 years
the ads that I'm really wanting to
change a lot are pretty low and when
you're in a really Dynamic industry
that's a problem and so okay that was
like kind of my first revelation on this
and then when I looked to hiring
I can remember when I started my job we
needed cyber people and I go out there
and I look unemployment in the US was
almost 10 can't find them okay it's ten
percent and I can't find the people okay
what's the issue okay they're not
teaching the right things
that led me down a path and it was
Serendipity that I happened to do a
review of social Corporate social
responsibility we had this one little
fledgling School in a low-income area
and high school with a community college
we gave them internships Direction our
curriculum oh and behold we could hire
these kids
I said Hmm this is not CSR like I just
found a new talent pool which takes me
to now what I'm doing in my post you
know post-retirement I'm like this idea
that don't hire just for a college
degree we had 99 of our hires were
college and phds and I'm all for it so
you're very don't go I'm deeply offended
no you should not be I and I you know
I'm Vice chair at Northwestern one of
the device here but but I said I just
really like aptitude does not equal
access these people didn't have access
but they had aptitude it changed my
whole view to skills first and so now
for hiring that's kind of a long story
to tell you the number one thing I would
hire for now is somebody's willingness
to learn you know and you can test you
can try different ways but their
curiosity and willingness to learn hands
down I will take that trait over
anything else they have so the interview
process the question changed everything
changed the kind of things you talk to
them about is try to get at how curious
they are about the world testing and I
mean there's we triangulated around it
lots of ways and now look they're at the
heart of it what it would do is change
you don't think of buying skills you see
you think of building skills and when
you think that way with so many people
and I think this country many developed
countries being disenfranchised
you got to bring them back into the
workforce somehow and they got to get
some kind of contemporary skills and if
you took that approach you can bring
them back into the workforce yeah I
think some interesting combination of
humility and passion because like you
said experts sometimes lack humility if
they call themselves an expert for a few
too many years so you have to have that
beginner's mind and a passion to be able
to uh aggressively constantly be a
beginner at everything and learn and
learn and learn you know I I saw it
firsthand when we were beginning this
path you know down the cloud and Ai and
we said and people say oh IBM you know
it's existential they got to change and
all these things and and I did hire a
lot of people from outside very willing
to learn new things come on in come on
in
and I sometimes say shiny objects
trained in shiny objects come on in but
I saw something it was another one of
these you're not a shiny object I'm not
saying that it's uh but I learned
something okay some of them did
fantastic
and others they're like well let me
school you on everything but they didn't
realize like we did really Mission
critical work and then break a bank I
mean they would not understand the
certain kind of security and the
auditability and everything they had to
go on and then I watched IBM people say
oh I actually could learn something some
were like yeah okay I don't know how to
do that's a really good thing I could
learn and in the end there was not like
one group was a winner one was a loser
the winners were the people who were
willing to learn from each other I mean
it was to me it was very Stark example
of that point and I and I saw it
firsthand so that's why I'm so committed
to this idea about skills first and
that's how people should be hired
promoted paid you name it yeah the AI in
general it seems like nobody really
understand is now
what the future will look like we're all
trying to figure it out so like what you
know IBM will look like in 50 years uh
in relation to the the software business
to AI is unknown what Google will look
like what all these companies were
trying to figure it out out and that
means constantly learning
taking risks all of those things and
nobody's really skilled in AI It's like
because you're absolutely right that's
right I couldn't agree more with you on
that you uh you wrote In the book uh
speaking of hiring quote my drive for
Perfection often meant I only focused on
what needed to change without
acknowledging the positive this could
keep people from trusting themselves it
could take me a while to learn that just
because I could point something out
didn't mean I should
I still spotted errors but I became more
deliberate about what I mentioned and
sent back to get fixed I also tried to
curtail my tendency to micromanage and
let people execute I had to stop
assuming my way was the best or only way
I was learning the giving other people
control builds their confidence and
they're constantly trying to control
people destroys it so what's the right
balance between showing the way and
helping people find the way
that is a good question
because
like a really flip answer would be
as it gets bigger you have no choice but
to just you know you can't do it you
have to
you have to tell or show I mean
you've got to let people find their way
because it's so big you can't right
that's an obvious answer scope of work
bigger it gets okay I've gotta let more
stuff go
but
I have always believed that a a Leader's
job is to do as well
and I think there's like a few areas
that are really important that you
always do now it doesn't meaning you're
showing so like when it has to do with
values and value-based decisions like I
think it's really important to
constantly
show people that you you walk your talk
on that kind of thing is super important
and I actually think it's a struggle
young companies have because the values
aren't deeply rooted and when a storm
comes it's easy to uproot and
um so I always felt like when it was
that time I showed it I got taught that
so young as at IBM and even General
Motors that
um
in fact I write I do write about that in
the book first time I was a manager I
had a gentleman telling dirty jokes and
not to me but to other people and it
really offended people and some of the
women this is this is the very early 80s
and
they came said something I talked to my
boss I'm a first time manager and he was
unequivocal with what I should do he
said and this was a top performer it
stops immediately or you fire him
so there are a few areas like that that
I actually think you have to always
continue to role model and show right I
that to me isn't the kind that like when
do you let go of stuff right so the
values and relationships with with
clients yeah whatever you're in service
of and and the other thing was I really
felt was really important to role model
learning right so
you know I can remember when we started
down the journey
and we went on to this thing called it
think Academy IBM's longtime motto have
been think and we said okay I'm gonna
make the first Friday of every month
compulsory education
and okay I mean everybody like everybody
I don't care what your job is okay when
the whole company has to transform
everybody's got to get kind of have some
skin in this game and understand it I
taught the first hour of every month for
four years now nice okay I had to learn
something so
but it made me but I've like okay if I
can teach this you can do it right I
mean you know kind of thing so it was a
compulsory uh Thursday night education
for you oh a little bit I'm a little
better prepared than that but yes you're
so right yes so you you prepare yeah
you like to prepare yeah but there's
roots in that go back deeply deeply
deeply deeply I and I think it's an
interesting reason so why do why are you
you're preparer my friend yeah yes you
are you prepare for your interviews uh
sure the rest you Wing yeah I Wing but
that's okay I mean you don't have to
prepare everything I don't prepare
everything either no but I I
unfortunately Wing stuff I save it to
last minute I I push everything I'm
always almost late and I don't know why
that is I mean there's some deep
psychological thing we should probably
investigate but it's probably the
anxiety
brings out the performance that can be
that's very true with some people I mean
so I'm a programming engineer at heart
and so so programmers famously
overestimate or underestimate sorry how
long that something's going to take and
so I just everything always
underestimate and it's almost as if I
want to feel this chaos of anxiety of a
deadline or something like this
otherwise I'll be lazy sitting on a
beach with a pina colada and relaxing
yeah I don't know so that we have to
know ourselves but for you for me you
like to prepare yeah it came from a few
different places I mean one would have
been as a as a kid I think
um
I was not a memorizer and my brother is
brilliant he can he read it once boom
done and so I always wanted to
understand like how something happened
it didn't matter what it was I was doing
it whether it was algebra theorems I
always wanted don't give me the answer
don't give me the answer you know I want
to figure it out figure out so I could
reproduce it again and didn't have to
memorize so it started with that and
then over time
okay so I was in university in the 70s
when I was in engineering school I was
the only woman you know I meet people
still to this day and they're like oh I
remember you I'm like yeah sorry I don't
remember you there were 30 of you wanted
me and I I think you already get that
feeling of okay I better really study
hard because whatever I say is going to
be remembered in this class good or bad
and it started there so in some ways
I did it for two reasons early on I
think it was a shield for confidence
the more I studied the more prepared I
was the more confident that's probably
still True to this day
the the second reason I did it evolved
over time and became different to
prepare
um if I was really prepared
then when we're in the moment I can
really listen to you see because I don't
have to be doing all this stuff on the
fly in my head and I could actually take
things I know and maybe help the
situation so it really became a way that
I could be present in in the moment and
I think it's something a lot of people
that in the moment I I learned it from
my husband he doesn't prepare by the way
at all so that's not it but but I
watched the in the moment the negative
example no no no and I'm not going to
change that as he says he's a type c I'm
an A okay how love works yeah and I have
been married 43 years and that seems to
work so but that idea that you could be
in the moment with people is a really
important thing yeah so the preparation
gives you the freedom to really be
present
so just a linger on the uh you mentioned
your brother and uh it seems like in the
book that you really had to
uh work hard when you study to to sort
of
um given that you weren't good at
memorization you really truly deeply
wanted to understand the stuff and you
put in the hard work and that seems to
persist throughout your career so
um you know hard work is often
associated with um
sort of has negative associations well
maybe with burnout with dissatisfaction
is there some aspect of hard work at the
core of who you are that led to
happiness for you
did you enjoy it I enjoyed it so I will
be the first and I'm I'm really careful
to say that to people because I don't
think everyone should associate G to do
what you did you have to there's only
one route there right and that's just
not true and I I do it because I like it
in fact I'm careful and as time goes on
you have to be careful as more and more
people watch you whether you like it
you're a role model or not you are a
role model for people whether you know
it like it want it does not matter I
learned that the hard way and I would
have to say people hey just because I do
this does not mean I do it for these
reasons right this would be really
explicit and I'd come to believe usually
when people say the word power I don't
know do you have a positive or negative
notion when I say the word power we just
do incredibly negative one yeah for some
stereotype or some view that that it
somebody's abused it in some way you can
read the newspaper somebody's doing
something
um personal people like I'll ask people
do you want power and they're like oh no
I'd rather do good yeah and I think the
irony is you need power to do good and
so that sort of led me down to in
it was I thought about my own life right
because it's it starts in a
like many of us you know you don't have
a lot but you don't know that because
you're like everybody else around you at
that time and a one end tragedy right my
father leaves my mother uh homeless no
money no food nothing four kids she's
never worked a day in her life outside
of a home
and I the irony that I hear I would end
up is the ninth CEO of one of America's
iconic companies
and now I co-chair this group 110 and
that journey I said the biggest thing I
learned was you could do really hard
meaningful things in a positive way so
now you asked me about why do I work so
hard
I ended up writing the book in three
pieces
for this reason when you really think of
your life in power
I thought it kind of felt like a pebble
in water like there's a ring about
you really care about yourself and like
the power of yourself power of me
there's a time it transcends to that you
are working with and for others and
another moment when it becomes like
about Society so my hard work
I'd ask you one day sit really hard and
think about when you close your eyes who
do you see from your early life right
and what did you learn and maybe it's
not that hard for you I mean it was
it's funny the things then
if I really looked at it it's no
surprise what I do today and that hard
work part my great grandma as uh you and
I were comparing notes on on Russia
right and never spoke English spoke
Russian came here to this country was a
cleaning person at the Wrigley building
in Chicago
yet if she hadn't saved every dime she
made
my mother wouldn't have a home and
wouldn't have had car right what did I
learn from that hard work in fact
actually she when I went to college
she's like you know you really should be
on a farm you're so big and strong you
know that was her view and then my
grandmother
another tragic life what did she do
though and think how long that's in the
40s the 50s she made lampshades and she
taught me how to sew right so I could
sew clothes when we couldn't afford them
but my my memory of my grandma is
working seven days a week sewing
lampshades and then here comes my mom in
her situation who who climbs her way out
of it so I associate that with well
strong women by the way all strong women
and I associate hard work with
how you are sure you can always take
care of yourself and so I think that the
roots go way back there and they were
always teaching something right my great
grandma was teaching me how to cook how
to work a farm even though I didn't need
to be on a farm my grandma taught me you
know here's how to sew here's how to run
a business and then my mother would
teach us that look but just a little bit
of Education look at the difference it
could make right so anyways that's a
long answer too I think that hard work
thing is really deeply rooted from that
background it gives you a way out from
Hard Times yeah you know I think I've
seen you on other podcasts say
I thought I did do you want to plan B
didn't you say no you would not like a
plan B yeah I don't know because you're
like I would prefer my back up against
am I remembering story like that
you seem to like at least certain
moments in your life seem to uh do well
in Desperate Times true enough I true
enough that's true I I learned that very
well but I also think
um that maybe this is the same kind of
plan B I think of it as like I was
taught like always be able to take care
of yourself
don't have to rely on someone else sure
and and I think that to me so so that's
my plan B I can take care of myself and
it's it's even after what I lived
through with my father I thought well
this set of bar for bad after this
nothing's bad and and that does it's a
very freeing thought the being able to
take care of yourself is that you mean
practically or do you mean just the
self-belief that I'll figure it out I'll
figure it out and practically both right
so you wrote quote I vividly remember
the last two weeks of my freshman year
when I only had 25 cents left I put the
quarter in a clear plastic box on my
desk and just stared at it this is it I
thought no more money
so do you think there's some aspect of
that Financial stress even desperation
just being hungry did that play a role
in that drive that led to your success
to be the the CEO you know one of the
great companies ever it's a really
interesting question because I was just
talking to another colleague who's CEO
of another great American company this
weekend and
he mentioned to me about all this
adversity and he said I said to him I
said
do you think
part of your success is because you had
bad stuff happen yeah
and he said yes you know and so I I
guess I'd be
lying if I didn't say I don't think you
have to have tragedy but it does teach
you like one really important thing is
that there is always a way forward
always and it's in your control I think
there's probably wisdom for mentorship
there or whether you're a parent or a
mentor
that uh easy times don't result in
growth yeah I've heard a lot of my
friends and they they worry they said
Gee my kids have never had bad times
yeah and so what you know what happens
here so I don't know is it is it
required
um and why you end up not required but
it sure doesn't hurt you had this good
line about an advice you were given that
growth and comfort never coexist growth
and comfort never coexist and you have
to get used to that thought if someone
said that they think of me like one of
the more profound sort of lessons I had
um in the eyes it's from my husband and
uh which is even more you know funny
actually you could just steal it I mean
you know I have shamelessly as he'll
tell you
um okay so the story behind growth and
comfort never coexist but honestly
I think it's been a really freeing
thought for me and it's helped me
immensely since
mid-career
and um as I write about it in the book I
mid-career and I'd been running a pretty
big business actually and the fella I
work for is going to get a new job it's
going to get promoted he calls me and he
says hey you're gonna get my job I
really want you to have it and I said to
him no way I I said I'm not ready for
that job I got a lot more things I got
to learn that is like a huge job around
the world every product line development
you name it every function I can't do it
it looked at me
he says I think you should go to the
interview
I went to interview the next day blah
blah blah guy says to me looks at me and
he says I want to offer you that job
and I said
I would like to think about it I said I
want to go home and talk to my husband
about it
kind of looked at me okay
I went home my husband is sitting there
and he says to me I went on and on about
the story Etc and he says
do you think a man would have answered
it that way and I said
he says I know you he's like six months
you're going to be bored and you all you
can think of is what you don't know and
he said I know these other people you
have way more skill than them and they
think they could do it and he's like why
why and and for me it internalized this
feeling that
and it it I'm gonna I am gonna say
something it's a bit stereotype that it
resonates with many many women and I'll
ask you if it does after is that either
the most harsh critic of themselves and
so this idea that I Won't Grow unless I
can feel uncomfortable doesn't mean I
always have to show it by the way so
that's why I meant growth and comfort
can never coexist so I got I was like
he's exactly right now the end of that
story is I went in I took the job when I
went back to the man who was really my
mentor looking out for me and he he
looked at me and he said don't ever do
that again and I said I understand
because it was okay to be uncomfortable
I didn't have to use I mean
now I would take stack of the things I
can do right and really think or I look
for times to be uncomfortable because I
know if I am nervous
like I don't know if you're nervous to
meet me we never met in real person I'm
still terrified no you're not but then
it means you're learning something right
holding it together so well that to me
matters I think it's interesting the
maybe you could speak to the the sort of
the self-critical thing inside your
inside your brain because I think
sometimes
um is talked about that women have that
um but I have that definitely and I
think that's not just solely property in
the workplace but I also want to sort of
push back on the idea that that's a bad
thing that you should silence because I
think that anxiety that leads to growth
also that's like this discomfort so
there's this weird balance you have to
have between that self-critical engine
and confidence yeah I think that's a
good point you have to kind of dance
because if you're super confident people
will value you higher that's important
but if you're way too confident maybe in
the short term you'll gain but in the
long term you won't grow very good point
so I can't really disagree with that and
and to me even when I took on jobs
I always felt people say well is it you
know what point are you confident enough
and I came to sort of believe again a
theme of my beliefs that
if I was willing to ask lots of
questions and understood enough that's
all I needed to know
let me ask you about your husband a
little bit
so you write in the book you're you're
writing the book he's just like jumping
around like I said I'm a bit of a
romantic so how did you meet your
husband so I met my husband when I was
19 years old so I was a young kid
um and I met him when I had a General
Motors scholarship so I was at
Northwestern University through my first
two years I had a lot of loans financial
aid and a professor said hey you should
sign up for this interview they're
looking to bring forward diverse
candidates through their management
track now these programs don't exist
anymore like that they will pay your
tuition your room and board your
expenses uh Northwestern other Ivy
League school these very expensive
schools and um I think you'd be a good
fit
I am eternally thankful for that advice
I went and I interviewed I actually got
the scholarship
um I mean without it I'd have graduated
with hundreds of thousands of dollars of
debt
um so part of that was in the summer I
had to work in Detroit I lived a little
room by a cement plant uh not theirs but
I mean that's all I could afford it's
very romantic very very romantic and the
person who owned the house said you know
hey I'm having a party you're not
invited I'm going to fix you up with
someone tonight
and that turned out to be my husband and
so it was a blind date is uh is how we
very first and then it was over it was
story was written yep uh let's if it's
okay just zoom out to uh you mentioned
uh Power and good power a few times so
if we can just even talk about it your
your book is called good power leading
positive change in our lives working
world
what is good Paul what's the essence of
good power so the essence of it would be
doing something hard or meaningful but
in a positive way
um I would also tell you I hope one day
I'm remembered for how I did things
not just for what I did I think that
could almost be more important and I
think it's a choice we can all make so
the essence to me of good power if I had
a contrast good to bad let's say would
be that first off
you have to embrace and navigate tension
this is the world we live in
and by embracing tension not running
from it you would Bridge divides that
unites people not divides them it's hard
thing to do but you can do it
you do it with respect which is the
opposite of fear a lot of people think
way to get things done is fear and then
the third thing would be you gotta
celebrate some progress versus
perfection
because I also think that's what stops a
lot of things from happening because you
know if you go for whatever your
definition of perfect is it can it's
either polarization or parallelization I
mean if something happens in there
versus no no I can
if don't worry about getting to that
actual exact end point if I keep taking
a step forward of progress really tough
stuff can get done and so my view of
that is like honestly I hope it can you
know I said it's like a memoir with
purpose I'm only doing it it was a
really hard thing for me to do because I
don't actually talk about all these
things and I had to nobody cares about
your like scientific description of this
they want the stories in your life to
bring it alive so it's a memoir with
purpose and in the writing of it it
became the power of me the power of we
and the power of us the idea that you
build a foundation when you're young
mostly from my work life the power of we
which says
I kind of in retrospect could see five
principles on how to really Drive change
um that would be done in a good way and
then eventually you could scale that the
power really of us which is what I'm
doing about finding better jobs for more
people now that I code this co-chair an
organization called 110. so that essence
of
navigate tensions do it respectfully
celebrate progress
and
give me indulge me one more minute these
sort of again it's retrospect that I I
didn't know this in the moment I had to
learn it I learned it I am blessed by a
lot of people I worked with and around
and
but some of the the principles like the
first one is says
if you're going to do something change
something do something you got to be in
service of something
being in service of is really different
than serving
super different
and like I just had my knee replaced
and I interviewed all these doctors you
can tell the difference of the guy who's
going to do a surgery hey my surgery is
fine I really don't care whether you can
walk and do the stuff you want to do
again but because my surgery is fine
your Hardware is good
I actually had some trouble
and I had a Doctor Who's like you know
this doesn't sound right I'm coming to
you like the surgery was fine it was me
that was reacting wrong to it and he
didn't care until I could walk again
okay there's a big difference in those
two things and it's true in any business
you have
um a waiter serves you food okay serves
his food he did his job or did he carry
he had a good time so that thought to be
in service of it took me a while to get
that like to try to write it to get that
across because I think it's like so
fundamental
if people were really in service of
something you got to believe that if I
fulfill your needs at the end of the day
mine will be fulfilled
and and that is that Essence that makes
it so different and then the second part
second principle is about building
belief which is I gotta hope you'll
voluntarily believe in a new future or
some alternate reality and you will use
your discretionary energy versus me
ordering you
y'all get so much more done then the
Third change in endure we kind of talked
about that earlier
focus more on the how and the skills
and then the pardon good Tech and being
resilient so anyways I I just felt that
like good Tech everybody's a tech
company I don't care what you do today
and there's some fundamental things you
got to do in fact pick up today's any
newspaper right chat GPT you're an AI
guy
all right I I believe one of the tenants
of good Tech is
it's like responsibility for the long
term it says so if you're going to
invent something you better look at its
upside and its downside like we did
Quantum computing
great a lot of great stuff right
materials development uh risk management
calculations endless lists one day on
the other side it can break encryption
that's bad thing so we worked equally
hard on all the algorithms that would
sustain quantum
I I think with chat okay great
there's equal in in there are people
working on it but like okay the things
that say hey
I can tell this was written with that
right because the implications on how
people learn right if this is not a
great thing if all it does is do your
homework that is not the idea of
homework as someone who likes to studies
hard but anyways you get my point it's
just the upside the downside and that
there could be much larger implications
that are much more difficult to predict
and that's our response absolutely to
really work hard to to to figure that I
was talking to AI ethics a decade ago
and I'm like why Won't Anyone listen to
us you know I'm it's that's another one
of those values things that you realize
hey if I want to bring technology in the
world I better bring it safely right and
that to me comes with when you're an
older company that's been around you
realize that Society gave you a license
to operate and it can take it away and
we see that happen to companies and
therefore you're like okay
like why I feel so strong about skills
hey if I'm going to bring in it's going
to create all these new jobs job
dislocation then I should help on trying
to help people get new skills anyways
that's a long answer to what good Tech
but the idea that there's kind of in
retrospect a set of principles you could
look at and maybe learn something from
my sort of rocky road through there
but it started with the power of we and
there's that big leap I think that
propagates to the things you're saying
which is the leap from focusing on
yourself to the focusing on others so
that having that empathy you've said at
some point in our lives and careers our
attention turns from ourselves to others
we still have our own goals but we
recognize that our actions affect many
and it is impossible to achieve anything
truly meaningful alone so it's do you I
think maybe you can correct me but
ultimate good power is about
collaboration and maybe in you know in a
large companies like delegation on on
great teams the ultimate good power is
actually doing something for society
that would be my ultimate definition
because about the results of the things
yeah but how it's done right the how
it's done and so
um
you know when you set a leap do you
think you people make a leap when they
go from thinking about themselves to
others do you think it's a leap or do
you think it kind of just is a sort of
slow point I think the leap is in
deciding that this is uh oh it's like
deciding that you will
care about others that this is it's like
it's like a leap of going to the gym for
the first time it's yes it takes a long
time to develop that and to actually
care but the decision that I'm going to
actually care about other human beings
yeah yeah okay or at least like yeah it
just feels like a deliberate action you
take of empathy Yeah because sometimes I
think it happens a little it's maybe not
as deliberate yeah it is a little bit
more gradual because it might happen
because you realize that geez I can't
get this done alone so I gotta have
other people with me but how do I get
them to help me do something so I think
it does help and happen a little bit
more gradually and as you get more
confident you start to not think so much
that it's about you and you start to
think about this other thing you're
trying to accomplish and so that's why I
felt it was a little more uh gradual I
also felt like I can remember so well
you know
this idea that um again now we're in the
80s 90s I'm a woman I'm in technology
and I was down in Australia at a
conference
and I gave this great speech again me
power of me you know I'm thinking give
this great speech financial services
this guy man walks up to me after I
think he's gonna like ask me some great
question and he said to me I wish my
daughter could have been here
and in that moment
and I and at that point up to then I'd
always been about look please don't
notice I'm a woman do not notice that I
am I just want to be recognized for my
work
crossing over from me to we
like it or not I was a role model for
some number of people
and
maybe I didn't want to be but that
didn't really matter
so I could either accept that and
embrace it or not I think it's a good
example of that transition I did have a
little Epiphany with that happening and
then I'm like okay because I would
always be like no I won't go on a
Women's Conference I won't talk here I
won't you know no no no
um but then I sort of realized wait a
second you know that'll say you cannot
be what you cannot see
and I I said to myself what oh wait a
second okay
I am in these positions I have a
responsibility too and it's two others
and that's what I meant I felt like it
can be somewhat gradual that you come
and you may have these like pivotal
moments that you see it but then you
feel it and you sort of move over that
transom into the power of Lee you're one
of the most powerful Tech leaders ever
and as you mentioned the word power you
know the old saying goes power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
was there an aspect of power that was
uh
that you had to resist
its ability to corrupt your mind to um
to sort of delete dilute you into
thinking you're smarter than you are
that kind of all the ways that's very
dangerous I agree with I mean I think
you got to be careful who you surround
yourself with that's how I would answer
that question right and people who will
hold the mirror up to you can be done in
a very positive way by the way it
doesn't mean you know but uh that we're
sycophants you cannot have that right I
mean it's like I always say to someone
like um Hey listen to me tell me tell me
what would make me better or do
something or I have a husband that'll do
that for me quite easily by the way
you'll always tell me he's the one okay
I have been surrounded myself with a
number of people that will do that and I
think you have to have that I had a a
woman that worked with me for a very
long time and um at one time we were
competitors and then at some point she
started to work for me and stayed with
me for quite a while and she was one of
the few people that would tell me the
truth in in you know sometimes that's
like enough already and and she'd be
like do not roll your eyes at this and
you absolutely have got to have that and
and I think it also comes it'll go back
to my complete commit commitment to
inclusion and diversity because you've
got to have that variety around you
you'll get a better product and a better
answer at the end of the day and so that
to resist that Allure I think it's
around about who you surround yourself
with current politics would say that too
so you uh you write about in general you
value diversity a lot so can you speak
to almost like philosophically what does
diversity mean to you
diversity to me means
I'm gonna get a better product a better
answer
I value different views and so it's
inclusion so
I was saying inclusion diversity is a
number inclusion is a choice
and you can make that choice every
single day
it's a good line
I really believe and I've witnessed it
that I've had when my teams are diverse
I get a better answer my friends are
diverse I have a better life I mean all
these kinds of things and so
um I also believe it's like no Silver
Thread there's no easy way you have to
authentically believe it I mean do you
authentically believe that that
diversity is a good thing yeah but I I
believe the diversity it like broadly I
very broadly Define it yeah so like
there's you know sometimes the way
diversities looked at with the the way
diversity is used today is like surface
level characteristics which are also
important um but they're usually
reflective of something else which is a
diversity of background A diversity of
thought A diversity of struggle uh some
people that grow up middle class uh
versus poor different countries
different motivations all of that yeah
it's beautiful and different people from
very different walks of life get
together yeah it's beautiful to see but
like sometimes it's very difficult to
get
at that on a sheet of paper of of the
characteristics that defines the
difference I know so it is it's just
like oh I can't hire exactly for or if
I'm trying to and but I do know one
thing that when people say well I can't
find these kind of people I'm looking
for I'm like you're just not looking in
the right places right you have to open
them just you gotta really open up new
pools yeah right you have to think yeah
like everybody you don't have to have a
PhD just like you said yeah sorry to say
it you know I know I know it's very
valuable but you have trust me but well
it could it just like you said it could
even be a a negative so you mentioned uh
like for good power you are a CEO of uh
you are a CEO for a long time of a
public company were there times when
there was pressure to sacrifice
what is good for the world
um for the bottom line
in order to do it because there were a
lot of times for that I mean I I think
every company faces that today and that
um I always felt like there's so much
discussion about stakeholder capitalism
right do you just serve a shareholder do
you have multiple
I have always found and I've been very
vocal about that topic that um when I
participated The Business Roundtable
wrote up a new purpose statement that
had multiple stakeholders
I think it's common sense like if you're
going to be 100 years old you only get
there because you actually do at some
time balance all these different
stakeholders in what it is that you do
and short term long term all these
trade-offs and I always say people who
write about it they write about it black
and white but I have to live in a gray
World it nothing I've ever done has been
in a black and white World hardly maybe
things of values that I had to answer
but most of it is great and so
um I think back lots of different
decisions
um I think back as you would well
remember you're a student of History IBM
was one of the really The Originators of
the semiconductor industry and certainly
of commercializing the semiconductor
industry great r d and Manufacturing but
it is a game of volume and so when I
came on we were still manufacturing r d
and Manufacturing our own chips we were
losing a lot of money yet here we had to
fight a war on cloud and Ai and so okay
now shareholders would say fine shut it
down okay those chips also power some of
the most important systems that power
these the banks of today if I just shut
it down what would that do and so okay
the answer wasn't just stop it the
answer wasn't just keep putting money
into it the answer was and we had to
kind of sit in an uncomfortable spot
till we found a way I mean it's going to
sound so basic but you as an engineer
understand it we had to separate it was
a very integrated process of research
development and Manufacturing and you'd
also you'd be perfecting things in
manufacturing and bits these were very
high performance chips
we had to be able to separate those we
eventually found a way to do that so
that we could
um take the manufacturing elsewhere and
we would maintain the r d it's a I think
it's a great example of the question you
just asked because
there was people would have applaud it
others would have been this was horrible
or we had a financial roadmap that had
been put in place that said I'll make
this amount EPS by this date there came
a time we couldn't honor it because we
had to invest and so there's a million
of these decisions I think most people
if they're run firms any size firm
they're just one right after another
like that and you're always making that
short and long tension of what am I
giving up what is that partnership like
with the with the class because you work
with gigantic businesses and what what's
it like
sort of um
really forming a great relationship with
them understanding what their needs are
being service of their in terms of yeah
very simple
honor your promises
and that happens over time I mean in
service of you know which is often why
you could work with competitors because
if you are really in service of you and
you need something it takes two of us to
do it that becomes easier to do because
I really we both care you get what you
needed and so I can remember
um
during one of the times I was on a
European trip and
at the time a lot and this is still true
about views about technology and
National technology Giants and Global
ones and the pros and the cons and
countries want their own national
champions quite obvious I mean if I'm
France or Germany and um there was a lot
of discussion about security and data
and who was getting access to what and I
can remember being in one of the I was
with Chancellor Merkel I had met her
many times she's very well prepared very
well prepared every time as you would
know and
I started to explain all these things
about why how you know how we don't
share data how who it belongs to our
systems never had back doors and she
sort of stopped me
like you're one of the good guys like
stop now
that wasn't about me personally she's
she's talking about a company that's
acted consistent with values for decades
right so to me how you work with those
big kind of clients is you honor your
promises you you say what you do when
you do what you say and you act with
values over a long period of time and
that to me people say we're value it is
not a fluffy thing it is not a fluffy
thing it is a
I
I mean if I was starting a company now
I'd spend a lot of time on that and
you know why we do what we do and why
some things are tolerable and something
you know what's your fundamental beliefs
are and uh and many people sort of Zoom
past that stage right it's okay for a
while and never sacrifice that you would
never sacrifice that I don't think you
can so there is a lot of pressure when
you took over as CEO and there was 22
consecutive quarters of Revenue decline
between 2012 and the summer of 2017. so
it was a stressful time Maybe not maybe
you can correct me on that so uh as a
CEO what was it like going through that
time the decisions the tensions in terms
of investing versus making a profit
I always felt that that sense of urgency
was so high and even if I was calm on
the outside because you you have
one of the world's largest pensions so
so many people depend on you you have a
huge Workforce they're depending on you
you have clients whose businesses don't
run if you don't perform
Etc and shareholders of course right and
so
but I also am really clear this was
perhaps the largest reinvention IBM ever
had to undertake yes at a board that
understood that
in fact some people some of the
headlines were like this is existential
right I mean nobody gives you a right to
exist forever and there aren't many
texts you're the student of it they are
gone they are all gone and so if we
didn't reinvent ourselves we were going
to be extinct and so
now but you're big and it's like
changing what's that old saying can I
change
um the wheels while the Train's running
or something like that or the engines
while the plane's flying exactly and
that's what you have to do and that took
time and so you know Lex do I wish it
would have been faster absolutely but
the team worked so hard and in my in
that time frame 50 of the portfolio was
changed it's a very large company and
um
if you would I also divested 10 billion
dollars of businesses so if you would
look at that growth rate without
divestitures and currency which now
today everyone talks about currency back
then we were the only International guy
um net of divestitures and currency the
growth was flat it's flat great no but
flat for a big transformation I was
really proud of the team for what they
did that is actually pretty miraculous
to have made it through that I have my
little nephew one day and you would see
on TV occasionally when there would be
criticism and you'd say uh you know
Auntie doesn't does that make you mad
when they talk mean yeah and I just
looked at him and I said you know he
says how do you feel I said look I'm
doing what has to be done
and I happen to be the one there
and if you have great conviction and I
did
a great conviction I knew it was the
right thing I knew it would be needed
for IBM to live at second century and so
and my successor they have picked up
gone for it I mean you go back we did
the acquisition of red hat I mean we had
to find our way on cloud right we were
late to it so we had to find our way and
eventually that led us to hybrid cloud
we did a lot of work with red hat back
in 2017 oh we'd always done a lot of
work with them actually we're one of the
First Investors when they were first
formed
um but that was 2018 you know it took
quite a hit for even you know oh it was
the largest to then software acquisition
ever but it is the foundation right of
what is our hybrid Cloud play today and
doing very very well so but I had to
take a short-term hit for that right
short-term hit for a very large 34
billion dollar acquisition uh but it was
for all of us it was the right thing to
do so I think when you get really
centered on you know it's the right
thing to do you just keep going right so
the team had the vision they had the
belief and everything else so don't we
didn't always have exactly the right you
know this wasn't a Straight Arrow but
stay down you know you're right keep
going okay made a mistake you know
there's no bad mistake as long as you
learn from it right and and keep moving
so yes did it take longer but we are the
largest that was there could you maybe
just on a small tangent educate me a
little bit so red hat originally is
Linux open source distribution of Linux
but it's also Consulting well it's it's
a little bit of Consulting but it's
mostly software District it was mostly
software yeah absolutely absolutely so
but today uh IBM is very much this you
know service most I.T services in the
world has done by IBM there's so many so
many varied uh so basically if you have
issues problems to solve in in business
uh in the software space IBM can help
yes and so in in that my last year uh
our services business we broke it into
two pieces and one piece was spun off
into a company called kindral which is
managed Outsourcing
um keeping things running and they're
off creating their own company what IBM
then retained is really the part I built
with pwcc the big Consulting arm and so
today the IBM of today in 2023 is you
know at least ending 2022 was 30
Consulting and the other 70 would be uh
what would you consider software Cloud
AI so hybrid cloud and AI is the other
and some Hardware obviously still the
Mainframe is modernized Alive and
Kicking and still running some of the
most important things of every Bank you
can think of practically uh in the world
and so that is the IBM of today versus
perhaps you know in red hat is a big
piece and an important part of that
software portfolio and they had some
services with them for implementation
but it wasn't a very a very large part
and it's it's grown by Leaps and Bounds
you know because originally the belief
was everything was going to go to the
public cloud and at least
many people thought that way
we didn't and in fact we I mean we tried
we cured a public Cloud company we
really tried to work it but what we
found was a lot of the mission critical
work
it it was tuned for Consumer World it
wasn't tuned for the Enterprise so then
time is elapsing here though and you got
to be upscale and we didn't have any
application remember we're not an
application company so it wasn't like we
had an office we didn't have anything
that like pulled things out to the cloud
and so as we looked for what our best
what we really back to who you are we
really know Mission critical work we
know where it lives today and we know
how to make it live on the cloud which
led us down hybrid Cloud you know that
belief that the real world would turn
into there'll be things on traditional
that'll you'll never move because it
doesn't make sense they'll be private
clouds for you know have all the benefit
of the cloud but they just don't have
you know infinite expansion and then
they'll be public clouds and you're
gonna have to connect them and be secure
and that's what took us down the path
with red hat that belief the structure
of that is fundamentally different than
something that's consumer facing so the
the lesson you learn there is you can't
just reuse something that that's
optimized for consumers very interesting
point doesn't mean consumer companies
can't move up into the Enterprise
because obviously they have right but I
think it's very hard to take something
from the Enterprise and come on down
because it got to be simple consumable
all the things we talked about already
plus you have to have the relationships
with Enterprise yeah very different yeah
I mean you know our history right at one
time we had the PC business and you know
the short answer to why would we would
not do that is it's a consumer-facing
business we were good at the Enterprise
and that consumer business a highly
competitive got to be low cost all the
things that are not the same muscles
necessarily of being in an innovation
driven you know uh technology business
yeah but what is now Lenovo I guess
that's what it's just been done we are
extremely good at that so but not as
good as you're saying is it at an
Enterprise or it's not it was it was
almost very good at their PC World yes
but I wouldn't and they can sell into
the Enterprise yeah right but you as a
consumer can go buy a Lenovo too so look
at look in China right look in other
places so
um that's what I mean consumer you know
an end device and that was a big
decision because it would have been one
of the last things that had our logo on
it that sits in your hands right so when
a new generation says what does IBM do
right was that a difficult decision
this is a long time ago now it's like
2005. yeah so um they're all difficult
because it's not only things as people
um but it's back to knowing who you are
is how I would sum that up as right and
we were never great at making a lot of
money at that and you can remember
original as IBM PC than there were IBM
clones or you they even called IBM
clones back then
um as the field became highly highly
competitive and as things commoditized
we often as they commoditize we would
move them out and move on to the next
Innovation level
but because of that it's not as public
facing
the logos ever yeah isn't it true that
is very true that is actually a very
important point and that is you know
branding as you say one of the most
recognizable in a in a very highly
ranked brand strength around the world
and so
that's a trade-off I mean I can't you
know it because there was a time you'd
have something of IBM in your home or
right or a cash register as an example
you'd walk into a store actually they're
still in places that went to Toshiba can
you speak the Consulting a little bit
what does that entail to train up to
hire a Workforce that can be of service
to all kinds of different problems in
the software space in the tech space
yeah what's entailed in that
I mean you have to value a different set
of things right and so
you've got to always stay ahead it's
about hiring people who are willing to
learn it is about
um at the same time
in my view
it's what really drives you to be
customer-centric maybe you can educate
me
I think Consulting is a kind of
you roll in
and you try to solve problems that
businesses have like with expertise
right okay is that is that the process
of Consulting somewhat right so there's
that okay so fair enough when you say
that we're Consulting it's a really
broad spectrum I mean I think people
could be sitting here thinking it does
any it could be I just give advice and I
leave to all the way to I run your
systems right and I think it's it's
generally people use the word to cover
everything in that in that space so we
sort of fit in the spot which is we
would come in and live at that
intersection of business and technology
so yeah we could give you
recommendations and then we'd Implement
them and see them through because we
have the technology to go to the
implementation and see them through and
at the time back then that's what you
know there have been five of those that
have failed the companies that bought
other consulting firms and um so we were
okay that was the great thing about I
mean the harrowing thing about it was
here please go work on this none of the
others have ever succeeded before and um
yet on the other hand the great promise
was you could really clients were dying
at that time when we were we're doing
that just to get more value out of their
technology and have it really change the
way the business worked so I think of it
as how to improve business and apply
technology and see it all the way
through that's what we do today still
yeah they see it all the way through
yeah yes uh so let me say almost like a
personal question so that was a big
thing you were a part of that you led uh
in 2002 that you championed and helped I
should say negotiate the purchase of one
day the Consulting arm
um of pricewaterhousecoopers for 3.5
billion dollars so what was what were
some of the challenges of that that you
remember
personal and
business
at that time PW had to die really had to
divest and so they were in parallel
going to IPO right so we sort of swept
in at that point and said and we'd been
thinking about it a long time and uh
started to to work on that as an
acquisition so you know kind of
balancing which way would they go IPO or
acquisition and so the challenges are
obvious and part of it's why they went
with us as an acquisition big difference
to be a private firm than a public firm
very big I can remember one of the the
guys you know he asked somebody how long
you've been with IBM and the person
answered 143 quarters okay that's a
little enlightening about a business
model right
um so we had the challenges of being
private versus public you have the
challenge of when you acquire something
like that as I say you acquire Hearts
not Parts
um they could leave I mean you could
destroy your value by them leaving they
can walk right out the door I mean yes
you can put you know lots of restraints
but still uh that you have there and
then we had to really build a new
business model that people and clients
would you know see is valuable and be
willing to pay for and so we had to do
something that lived at that
intersection and say that how this was
unique is what we were doing so you had
the people aspect you had that they were
going to be private and they had or
public and they had always been private
their whole life and and then you had
the business model so and the others it
all failed that had tried to do this so
yeah it was a it was it was a tough
thing to do what about the personal side
of that that was a big leap step up for
you you've been in IBM for a long time
yeah this is this is a big sort of
leadership
uh like very impactful large-scale
leadership decisions yeah what was that
like
so
you know unlike in my career earlier
where I said I was changing jobs I said
I wasn't comfortable Etc so now here
fast forward 10 years and I'm like okay
honestly how I felt inside on one hand I
did what I learned like inventory which
you know how to do like you have some
good strengths that could work here
the other part of me said boy this is
really high profile and I felt and I can
remember saying to someone like this is
gonna kill me
or catapult probably nothing in between
and that wasn't terrifying to you that
was okay you're okay I was okay with
that because I I felt I knew enough you
know like these things I had and I'll
tell you the one thing I felt I knew the
best
um
Consultants of any
worth their weight
they really do care that they deliver
for an end client
and and I felt I understood service to a
client so well that what it meant to
really provide value so I knew we would
have like something that I knew the PWC
people more than anything wanted to
deliver value to those clients they had
next to them developing their people
that those were like the really two
things and that I could and I also knew
they felt they could do better if they
had more technology and we did so so
there really was a reason you know that
I could really believe in so I
authentically believed back to that
point and I also felt I had built some
of those skills to be able to do that
but I wouldn't call it terrifying but
but make no mistake like
it was very hard and it was it turned
out to be extremely successful by the
time we ended it was worth 19 one time I
stepped I ran it for oh goodness
gracious uh quite a long time I'm going
to say seven or eight nine years and
Uber 19 and a half billion dollars it
made 2.7 billion in profit it was very
consequential to IBM but the fact that
it was consequential is also very I mean
there was a time as we moved through it
I I I I can even remember it
um we just weren't meeting the goals as
fast as we should and some of it was
clients were like oh now you're IBM so I
mean some some things I knew would
happen but they happen so much faster it
would be things like clients would say
oh IBM cares about a quarter so let's
negotiate every quarter on these prices
right and you know when they were
private they didn't have these issues
well that had an impact on margins
really fast and and so that ability up a
lot of challenges you pick them up right
away and and and I thought oh boy I mean
if I don't get this turned around this
is really a problem and and the team
learned a lot of lessons I mean I
learned people I had to move out that I
learned that when people don't believe
they can do something they probably
won't do it so you know we wanted to run
the business at a certain level I I
really did have some great leaders but
they didn't really believe it could do
that and I finally had to come to terms
with if you don't really believe in
something you really aren't going to
probably make it happen at the end of
the day and so
we would change that we would have to
actually get some more help to help us
on doing so and but then it turned and I
can remember the day that we started
really getting the business to hum and
start to it was almost like finally and
I gave the team this little plaque this
little I was kind of corny paperweight
thing and um I'm gonna believe it
remember if it was Thomas Edison and he
said many of life's greatest failures
are people who gave up right before they
were going to be successful yes and it's
so true I mean there was also a governor
of Texas whose past but she had said
someone said what's the secret of your
success and and she said it's passion
and perseverance when everyone else
would have given up yeah and and I and I
feel that's what that taught me that
taught me like you no no matter how bad
this gets you are not giving up and this
now you can't keep doing the same thing
like the you know doctor this hurts oh
then stop doing it you know you can't
keep doing the same thing we had to keep
changing till we found our right way to
get the model to work right and uh
client work we never never had an issue
and kept so many of the people and now
we are 25 years almost later and uh a
number of them run parts of the IBM
business still today so it's it's it's
that old uh Maya Angelou saying when you
say what do I remember
they'll say you won't remember the
specifics of this but you'll remember
how you felt and that's kind of how I
feel and I think they do too the whole
team does of that like I'll get an
anniversary notes still on that on that
you know when you've been through
something like that together with people
so during the acquisition the the way
you knew the people
it's the right team are the ones that
could believe that this this uh
Consulting yes my degree with the IBM
and all that yeah I was lucky look I I
did things that helped that I mean I
knew that people joining us would feel
more comfortable if they had people
leading it that they recognized Etc but
um
again I learned those that didn't then I
eventually had to take you know some
action out but but pwcc had a lot of
really dedicated leaders to it and uh I
I give them a lot of credit well it's
amazing to see a thing that kind of
start at that that very stressful time
and then it turns out to be a success
yeah that's that's just beautiful to see
so uh what about the acquisition itself
is there something interesting to say
about the like what you learn about
maybe negotiation because there's a lot
of money involved too to me it was a
win-win and we both actually cared the
customers got value so there was this
like third thing that had a benefit not
them not a there was this third thing
and then you think that
people would have the wisdom of what
what it takes to have great negotiation
but yeah so it's a win-win is is one of
the ways you can have this but it's like
obvious to even say that right I mean if
you can back to being in service of
something we were both in service of
clients so in and then
you know I always say
when you have a negotiation with someone
um okay both parties always kind of walk
away a little bit okay that's good if
they both walk away going God I should
have got a little bit more okay but it's
okay but I should have got okay they're
both a little a little fussy when one
walks away and thinks they did great and
the other one did horrible they usually
is like born bad I mean because they
never work that way and I've always felt
that way with negotiations that um
you push too far down you will you
usually will be sorry you did that you
know so don't push too far I mean that's
ultimately what collaboration and
empathy means is you you're interested
in in the long-term success of everybody
together versus like your short time and
then you get the discretionary energy
from them versus like okay you you
screwed me here I'm done right
so let's even rewind even back uh no oh
no so do you feel like this is a
Nostalgia interview oh no let me just
ask the Romantic question what did you
love most about engineering computer
science electrical engineering so in
those early days from your degree to the
to the earth I I love that logic part of
it right and you do get a sense of
completion at some point when you reach
certain Milestones you know like yes it
worked or yes it you know that finite
answer to that so that's what I loved
about it I loved the problem solving of
it Computing what led you down that path
what Computing in general what made you
fall in love with with Computing with
engineering
it's probably that back to that desire
wanting to know how things work right
and so that's like a natural thing you
know math I loved math for that reason I
always wanted to study how did that you
know how did it get that to work kind of
thing so it goes back in that time but I
did start when I went when I started I
wasn't I was already in the engineering
school but my first thought was to be a
doctor that that was far more noble that
I should be a medical doctor until I
could not pass human reproduction as a
course and I thought the irony that I
could not I'm like I got all these
colored pencils I got these pictures
this is not working I'm going to stick
to math it was the only course in my
four-year college education I had to
take pass fail because otherwise I I
risked you know impairing my uh my my
grade point average engineering it is so
but after about 10 years you jumped from
the technical world of systems engineer
to a management a leadership role did
you miss at that time the sort of the
technical direct contribution versus
being a leader a manager that's an
interesting point like I like I say I've
always been sort of a do leader you know
so she never lost it I never really did
even you know and I think this is like
really important for today the best way
people learn is experientially I think
now you may there that's being a
generalization because their people can
learn all different ways right
so I've done things like with my whole
team
they all had to learn how to build Cloud
applications
we called it codoff and so you know I
don't care what your job is write code
you know and uh I remember when we were
trying to get the company to understand
AI we did something called a cognitive
Jam okay there's a reason we picked the
word cognitive by the way instead of AI
today we use the word AI
it was really symbolic it was to mean
this is to help you think not replace
your thinking there was so much in the
Zeitgeist about AI being a bad thing at
that time so that was why we picked a
mouthful of a word like cognitive and it
was like no no this is to help you
actually so do what you know do what you
do better or do something you haven't
yet learned and uh we did something
called the cognitive Jam but the whole
point was everybody in the company could
volunteer get on a team you either had
to build something that improved to one
of our products or did something for a
client or did a social
issue with AI
and again this goes back now
10 years and people did things from
bullying applications to you know
railroad stuff to whatever it was but it
got like a hundred thousand people to
understand you know viscerally what is
AI so that's a long answer to my belief
around experiential and so do you ever
give it up I I don't think so because I
actually think that's pretty good to get
your hands dirty in something you know
you can't do it you know depending what
you're doing your effort to do that will
be less but so even a CEO you tried to
always get your hands
I've played I mean still yeah I'm not
saying I'm any good at any of it you
know anymore but to build up intuition
yeah it's that really understand right
and not be afraid of yeah
like we mentioned at the beginning uh
IBM research has helped catalyze some of
the biggest accomplishments in Computing
and artificial intelligence history so
uh Deep Blue
IBM D blue versus Kasparov chess match
in 96 and 97. uh just just to ask kind
of like what your perception is what
your memory is of it what is what is
that Moment Like This seminal moment I
believe probably one of the greatest
moments in AI history when the machine
first beat a human at a thing that
humans you make a very interesting point
because it is like one of the first
demonstrations of using a game to like
bring something to people's
Consciousness right and into this date
people use games right to demonstrate
different things
um but at the time
funny and didn't necessarily think of it
so much as Ai and I'll tell you why I
was and I'm not a chess player you might
be a chess player so I'm not expert at
it but I think I understand properly of
Chess that chess has got a finite number
of moves that can be made therefore if
it's finite really what's a
demonstration of a super Computing right
it's about the amount of time and how
fast it can crunch through to find the
right move so in some ways I thought of
it as almost a bigger demonstration of
that but it is absolutely as you said it
it is was a motivator one of the big
Milestones of AI because it put in your
Consciousness that it's man
in this per in this other machine right
yeah I'm doing something so you saw it
as just a challenging competition
problem and this is a way to demonstrate
hardware and software computation at its
best yes I did but the thing is there is
a romantic notion that chess is the
embodiment of human intellect I mean
intelligence that you can't build a
machine that can beat a chess champion
in chess and the the fact that blessed
by not being a chess expert so it wasn't
like it's just a computation problem
it's a computation problem to me well
that's probably required to not be
paralyzed by the immensity of the task
yeah so that this is just solvable but
it was a very very I think that was a
powerful moment so speaking just as an
AI person that was uh
that
reinvigorated the dream you were a
little kid back then though right at
that at 95. you have to be like were you
uh you remember it actually at the
moment yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
what did you think at the moment about
it
uh
it was
awe-inspiring because
um especially sort of growing up in the
Soviet Union
you think especially if Gary Kasparov
and chess like your intuition is weak
about those things I didn't see it as
computation I thought of it as um
uh intelligence because
chess for a human being doesn't feel
like computation yeah it it feels like
some complicated uh relationship between
memory and patterns and intuition and
guts and Instinct and all of those like
so if you watch someone play that's what
you have to conclude right and so to see
a machine be able to uh be a human I
mean you get a little bit of that with
chagi PT now it's like language was to
us humans the thing that we kind of uh
surely the The Poetry of language is
something only humans can really have
it's going to be very difficult to
replicate the magic of a natural
language without deeply understanding
language but it seems like Chad GPT is
can do some incredible things with
language and uh um in uh in natural
language dialogue so but that was the
first moment in AI through all the AI
Winters from the 60s is the promise of
the it was it was wow this this is
possible for um
for for a simple set of algorithms to
accomplish something that we think of as
intelligence so that I that was truly
inspiring that maybe intelligence maybe
the human mind is just algorithms that
was the thought at the at the time and
of course now what the the funny thing
what happens is the moment you
accomplish it everyone says oh it's just
Brute Force algorithms it's silly
um and this continues at every single
time you pass a benchmark a threshold to
win a game people say oh well it's just
this it's just this it's just this and
that that
um I think that's funny and there's
going to be a moment when we're gonna
going to have to contend with AI systems
that
exhibit human-like emotions and feelings
and you have to start to have some
difficult discussions about well how do
we treat those beings and what role do
they have in society what are the rules
around that you know and this is really
exciting because that also puts a mirror
to ourselves to see okay what's the
right
way to to treat each other as human
beings because it's a it's a good test
for that it is because I always say it's
a um a reflection of humanity what a I
mean it's taught by what man you know
for bad stuff in the past you'll teach
it bad stuff for the future and which is
why I think you know like efforts to
regulate it are a Fool's ear and you
need to regulate uses not you know
because it's not the technology itself
is not inherently good or bad but how
it's used or taught can be good or bad
for sure right and so um that's to me
will unveil now a whole different way of
having to look at technology uh what
about another magical leap with the
early days of Watson with beating the
Jeopardy challenge what was your
experience like with Watson what's your
vision for Watson in general yeah and it
was really inspired by first chess right
and Casper off and then you come forward
in time and you know I think what Watson
did because you used a really important
word AI had kind of waxed and waned in
these winners right in and out in and
out popular not more money less money
you know in and out confidence no
confidence and so I think that was one
of the first times it brought to the
Forefront of people like oh I could
humanized it because here it is playing
against these two gentlemen and as you
did lose it first you know and then
finally finally one at the end of the
day and but what it was doing is making
you say hey natural language it's
actually understanding natural language
it's one of the first demonstrations of
natural language support and bit of
reasoning over lots of data right and so
that it could have access to a lot of
things come up with a conclusion on it
and to me that was a a really big moment
and I do think it brought to the
conscious of the public and in good ways
and bad because it probably set
expectations very high of like whoa what
this could be but and I still do believe
that it has got the ability to change
and help us man make better decisions
that so many decisions are not optimal
in this world you know even medical
decisions and it's right or wrong what
took us down a path of Health Care First
with our Ai and and we took many pivots
and I think there's a really valuable
lesson in what we learned one is that
actually I don't think the challenges
are the technology yes those are
challenges but the challenges are the
people taking out are the people
challenges around this right so do
people trust it
how will they use it I mean I saw that
straight up with with doctors and like
meaning they're so busy in the way
they've been taught to do something
do they really have time to learn
another way I saw it was a mistake when
you put it on top of processes it didn't
change kind of like Paving a cow path
didn't work I mean it was all human
change management around it that were
really its biggest challenges and
another valuable lesson we picked back
to you said you think of IBM as
moonshops we picked really hard problems
to start with I think you see a lot of
Technology now starts with really simple
problems and and by that it probably
starts to build trust because I start
little it's like oh I'm not ready to you
know Outsource my diagnosis to you but
I'll get some information here about a
test question so very different thinking
so a lot of things to learn we were
making a market at the time and when you
make a market you know choice of problem
you work on gets to be very important
when you're catching up well then it's a
scale game so very different thing and
so but Watson proved I think I mean I
hope I'm not being too
um
I think Watson brought AI back out a
winner for the world and that since then
there's just been you know one company
after another in Innovations and people
working on it and I have no regrets of
anything that we did we learned so much
and we probably rebuilt it many times
over it made it more modular
and today tybm a Watson is more about AI
inside of a lot of things if you think
of it that way which is more like an
ingredient versus it's a thing in and of
itself and I think that's how it'll
bring it to real value you know more as
an ingredient and it's so badly needed
and even back then the issue was so much
data like what do you ever do it you
can't get through it you can't use it
for anything you know this well it's
your profession so
um
we have to have it so that's a that's
going to propel it forward so it's part
of The Suite of tools that you you use
when you go to Enterprise and you try to
solve yeah problems AI for security Ai
and automated operations AI in your
robotics AI on your factory you know I
mean it's it's all part of and I think
and that's why even to this day
thousands I mean thousands and thousands
of clients of IBM still have the Watson
components that it's the AI being used
so it became a platform is how I would
say it right
um and an ingredient and that went
inside and Consultants like you said had
to learn
I had they had to learn
don't just put it on something you got
to rethink how that thing should work
because with the AI it could work
entirely differently and so I also felt
it could open up and still will open up
jobs to a lot of people because more
like an assistant and it could help me
be qualified to do something and we we
even years ago saw this with the French
banks very unionized but that idea that
you could
in this case the unions voted for it
because it felt people did a better job
and so
and that's this part about being really
dedicated to help it help Humanity not
destroy it speaking of which a funny
side note uh so Kubrick's uh uh two
thousand dollar Space Odyssey uh what do
you think about you know the fact that
HAL 9000 was named after IBM I really
don't think it was I know there's I
really don't I thought it could be more
fake news it's more fake news I have
done I've like researched this tried to
find any evidence and people have talked
to you know was it really you know one
letter it was one letter one letter also
right people don't know H is one letter
off of I a is one letter for Alpha B and
then L is one better off of that was the
I think that's a solution found
afterwards you know but here's what I
think it more was I do think it's one of
the early demonstrations of evil AI yeah
like can be taught bad I could push back
on that because it's presented as evil
in the movie because it hurts the AI
hurts people but it's a really
interesting ethical question because the
role of Hal 9000 is
um to carry out a successful mission
and so the question that is a human
question yeah it's not an AI question at
what what price you humans wage war they
there they pay very heavy costs for
um
for for a vision for a goal of a future
that creates a better world and so
that's the question certainly in space
doctors ask that question all the time
under limited resources who do I
allocate my time and money and efforts I
agree I like I said I've spent a decade
talking about this question of AI ethics
right and that that it needs really
considerable not just attention because
otherwise it will mirror everything we
love and everything we don't love and
again and that's the beauty in the eye
of Beholder right depending your culture
and everything else
with what you're doing and what you're
gonna do how do you think about it do
you think about the AI you're going to
develop as having guard rails dictated
by some of your beliefs or uh yeah for
sure so there's there's so many
interesting ways to do this the right
way and I don't think anyone has an
answer my I tend to believe that
transparency is really important so I
think some aspect of your work should be
open sourced
or at least have an open source
competitor that creates a kind of
forcing function for transparency of how
you do things so
um the other is I tend to believe maybe
it's because of the podcast and I've
just talked to a lot of people you
should know the people involved I agree
100 as opposed to hide behind a company
wall sometimes there's a pressure you
have a PR team you have to care for
investors and discussion and so on let's
protect let's surely not tweet not with
like and you form this bubble where you
have incredible Engineers doing
fascinating work and also doing work
that's
uh difficult complex human questions
being answered and we don't know about
any of them as a society and so we can't
really have that conversation even
though that conversation would be great
for hiring it would be great for
revealing the complexities of what the
company is facing so when the company
makes mistakes you understand that it
wasn't
malevolence or half-assedness and the
decision making is just a really hard
problem and so I think transparency is
just good for everybody
um and I mean in general just having a
lot of public conversations about this
is serious stuff it's uh
um that AI will have a transformative
impact on our society and it might do so
very very quickly through all kinds of
ways we're not expecting which is social
media recommendation systems they
they're at scale have impact on the way
we think on the way we consume news and
um the the the our growth like the kind
of stuff we consume to grow and learn
and become better human beings all of
that that's all Ai and then obviously
the the tools that run companies on
which we depend the infrastructure in
which we depend we need to know all
about those AI decisions and it's not as
simple as well we don't want the AI to
say
these specific set of bad things it's
unfortunately I don't believe it's
possible to it's not uh prevent
evil or uh bad things by creating a set
of cold mathematical rules yeah
unfortunately it's all fuzzy and gray
areas it's all giant mess it is I mean
you think about it Like a Knife a knife
can do good and a knife can do bad okay
you can't it's very hard it can't man
nice you can't ban knives and that this
is I think back it was probably 20 I
don't know 15 16. we did principles of
trust and transparency notice the word
transparency that belief that with AI it
should be explainable you should know
who taught it you should know the data
that went into training it you should
know who How It Was Written if it's
being used you have a right to know
these things and I I think those are
pretty to this day really powerful
principles to be followed right and and
part of it we ended up writing because
here we were when we're working on
particularly Healthcare like okay you
care who trained it in what and and
where it and that's uh that's sort of
simple you know that comes to your mind
you're like yeah that makes a lot of
sense for something important like that
but it's just in General
people won't trust the Technologies I
don't think unless they have
transparency into those things in the
end they won't really trust it I think a
lot of people would like to know
sort of um because a lot a lot of us I
certainly do suffer from imposter
syndrome that self-critical brain so you
know taking that big step into
leadership did you did you at times
suffer from imposter syndrome like how
did I get here do I really belong here
or did you were you able to summon the
courage and sort of the confidence to
really Step Up
it's very natural for someone like no
matter like the bigger the job gets
you turn and you look to the left and
the right and you see people around you
and you think what am I doing here right
but then you remember what you do and
there's no one else doing it and so you
get that confidence so I do hear a lot
of people talk about imposter syndrome
right and
I kind of actually this past year I've
spent some time helping people on that
topic and
part of the story so you have to believe
you you
have a right to be around like anyone
else does if you've prepared for that
moment you know and so
it's a bit more of a
I know it's hard to say it like a
confidence thing more than anything else
so yes there are times I look around but
then I think wow I'm in a position to
make something change so I I can't say I
have ever really dwelled on that feeling
for long okay so you just focused on the
work I have an opportunity you know it's
good or bad I just focus on the work
yeah good or bad yeah one important
lesson you said you've learned from your
mom is never let anyone else Define you
only you define who you are so what's
the
trajectory let's say of your
self-definition journey of you
discovering Who You Are
from having that very difficult
upbringing
you know they say pivotal moments happen
and you don't realize it when they're
happening
so most of my I feel like most of my
self-discovery it's been like something
happens in a year or two or some number
later I look back on it and say you know
I learned this from that it's like not
in the moment always with me that that
could just be how I am so I feel like
it's been
um know yourself is a good thing right
I've actually heard you say that on a
different podcasts when you ask people
questions you're like well it depends
you know like know yourself a bit right
and uh it's hard to know who you are
though there's a lot of things like you
said like uh like for me there's there's
moods when you're super soft critical
sometimes you're super confident and
there's many sometimes you're emotional
sometimes you're cool under pressure and
all those all those are the same human
beings yeah and I think that's fine
um self-awareness that's different
was there societal expectations and
Norms regarding gender that you felt in
um in your career you've spoken to that
a little bit but was there some aspect
of that that was constraining empowering
or both
you know I chose to never look at it
okay now whether that is right or wrong
and again I'm a product of the 70s and
70s and the 80s where
I think I was surrounded all the other
women around me viewed our way to get
ahead was just to work hard work hard
work hard and that was the way you
differentiated yourself and and that's
obvious it did help I mean there's no
doubt about it you're always for you
know you've learned a lot of things
which qualified opened up another door
opened up another door
I'm very mindful that I have worked for
companies that are very steeped in those
values of equal opportunity and so
nothing remarkable about that and I mean
when it was a wee kid I'm taught
hire a diverse team I get evaluated for
it I get evaluated if if my team has
built up their skills so this is that
you know when you're really formative
you're in a culture that that's what
it's valuing right so it becomes part of
you so
I say sometimes sister grinded did I
ever feel I was held back for that
reason no were there plenty of times
when
you know I read about a few stories in
the book I'm laying cables at night and
the guys are at the bar now I didn't
really want to go with them to the bar
anyways they'd be like we'll be back to
get you you know bye and I'm like okay
I mean I learned a lot so it didn't now
all that said back to my earlier story
about being a role model you know it
would be foolish to not believe that
there were times that that mattered and
I would say two things even not that
long ago
you know a colleague called me and was
talking about media and about women CEOs
and said do you notice that sometimes
when it's a women's CEO they call the
person by name and when it's a man they
call the company out not the person's
name exactly associated with the issue
and I said yeah well I think you have to
just understand much of what you do it
will be magnified because there are so
few of you and and sometimes it will be
you know really can be blown out of
proportion right and so that can happen
in
you've got to learn which in which way
now all that said on gender it is an
interesting thing with the book as I've
talked to you know having a book
it is one of my best friends or
frustrations I can't wait for my
daughter to read it
I say
well that's interesting do you think you
could read it
huh yeah it's fascinating it's an
interesting reaction and as here I am 40
years later that's an interesting
reaction right I and I say no the book I
really worked hard to write it for
everyone I just happened to be a woman
right
um but there's still that that there and
so look until I think people see and
never feel that they have a it doesn't
even matter whether there's a woman
could be another diverse group that
feels it it it's okay to ask those
questions and that's why actually I'm
okay talking about it because there were
times I felt it right there were times
in my life on my looks or my weight or
my clothing or endless numbers of things
that people would comment on that they
would not have commented on uh if it was
someone else
um now on the other hand when there's so
few of you and you know in there's good
and bad I mean there's benefit to that
too right you if you do good work you'll
be wrecking it's easier to be recognized
and so a pronicon and I think um I've
just you know grown up believing like my
advice to young women go into
engineering not because you're gonna be
an engineer it teaches you to style
problems and anything you job you do is
going to be solving problems things like
that are what I take away from that in
that Journey it is interesting that you
know I hear from women
that even on this podcast when I talk to
uh incredible women like yourself it is
inspiring to young women to hear it I
mean you like to see you talk to
somebody from turkey and then Turkish
people all get excited this is so true
so you get like somebody that looks like
you somebody that
um and the category could be tiny it
could be it can be huge and that's just
the reality of the world it is a reality
world and I um the work I do now to put
um this group called 110 put 1 million
black employees into the middle class
without college degrees get them the
right skills upwardly mobile jobs
so one of my last year's uh we had been
working on it just did Regular
leadership session at IBM and had our
black colleagues we're talking about
what did it feel like to be a black
leader and here these are extremely
accomplished people and I can remember
very well one telling a story about look
I felt
if I failed or succeeded it's not just
me it came from a country in Africa I
feel like the whole country is on my
shoulder my success for failure that's a
burden I mean like I don't feel that
burden uh not true as a woman CEO I did
feel like it you know even the headlines
when I was named said you know her
appointment will either you know her
success or failure will be a statement
for the whole gender kind of thing and
I didn't dwell on it but I meant that's
but I could see how people like you said
it could be a small group could be
whatever and so that is a lot of
pressure on people and they need Role
Models you're a role model for people
look at what you're able to do you do
these podcasts you understand your
science very well you're very well
prepared your ability to translate it to
people you know that's not an
insignificant thing and you may think oh
you know is that about the power of me
not really right and you obviously
believe you don't do this because you
just like sitting at a microphone you do
it because you think okay if I can get
people to say things that are really
valuable to the people they're going to
learn something I assume that is I mean
you never told me my interpretation is
that's why you do this podcast that you
feel like in service of other people
that you can bring them something unique
by the way you do this now I should ask
you why do you do it that's my
impression by the way can I just comment
on the fact that you keep asking me
really hard questions and I really I
appreciate I appreciate it
I'm really honored by it
as a fan of uh podcast myself
what I hope is to talk to people like
you and to show that you are a
fascinating and beautiful human being
outside of your actual accomplishments
also so sometimes people are very
focused on you know very specific things
about like you said science like what
what the actual work is whether it's
nuclear fusion or strategypt
I just want to show that it's
um because I see it at MIT and
everywhere it's just human beings trying
their best they're flawed but
um just realizing that all of these very
well accomplished people are all the
same yeah
well said and then so then regular
people and young people that they're
able to see you know I can do this too I
can have a very big impact right yeah
exactly it's like we're all kind of
imposters we're all like trying to
figure it out
to a certain degree uh so let me just
ask you about family you wrote that my
family still jokes that the reason I
never had children on my own was because
I had already raised my family they're
right so this is talking to you
upbringing but in general what was your
you know leading a giant company what
was the right place to find uh work-life
balance for you to have have time for
family yeah have time for away from work
and be successful so I had to learn that
and I might have said you know you're
the only one that can determine your own
work-life balance companies are innate
things I mean they will take everything
they can from you and it's not a bad
thing they just will as will bosses I
mean you give it they'll take it and
when people ask for you know I need roof
I'm like okay I had to come with terms
with the criminal was me if I needed
that balance I had to set those
boundaries and so when I comment about a
family because I am in extreme awe of
people with children who work it it is a
extremely hard thing to do I watch my
siblings I love my nieces and nephews
and
whoo you know a the emotional their pain
is your pain every minute of a day and
then you still have a job on top of it
and so when my mom had to go back to
school and had to work I was the one and
so when she couldn't go to the teacher
meeting I went to the teacher meeting
when and so in some ways and there's an
age gap between my brother and I and my
other two sisters and so I'm still they
they still call me Mama Bear even I mean
I'm extremely protective of all of them
and it is as if I had raised them and my
mom did a great job raising them I
didn't I but I was there and so
when it came time to have children and
my husband came from a family where his
father died and was raised by a single
mother very very similar endpoint
different reasons why he ended up you
know his father did not abandon them and
I don't want people to believe to do my
job you can have no children that is not
right I know other great women CEOs uh
Marilyn Houston who ran Lockheed Martin
extremely technical company maryborough
who runs General Motors Alan Coleman who
run Dupont these are all my friends to
this day
and they've been fantastic mothers and
husbands of good parents right and so I
talk about it because it was a choice we
made and so you know we both felt look
we'd reached a point where for his
reasons what he had to do I'd already
felt that way and that we were
comfortable just being great aunts and
uncles and I'm a great aunt you know I
regret well I like to think that for my
little guys and all and they're older
now but lots of them and
and there's no doubt though the choices
we made Mark and I that that made it
easier for me to focus on work I mean
it's just that's just math you know when
you've got less people to have to take
care of and so I'm very considerate of
that and I think much of it informed
many of the policies I put into because
I had such great empathy for those who
then still had these other
responsibilities and I desperately
wanted them all to stay in the workforce
so I can remember and my siblings have
been more successful than I by the way I
mean to my mother's credit and my one
sister who uh you know went to
Northwestern has an MBA built some of
the most sophisticated systems uh she
spent her whole career at Accenture and
just recently retired as a chief
executive of all of Consulting but at
one point she took off time to be to
spend with her family and then went back
go back to work she's talking to me and
she's like I don't know if I should go
back to work you know maybe life's pay
you know technology goes so fast it's
been a few years
I'm sitting there like what are you
talking about I'm like you know look at
her credentials if far outstanding I'm
like
and I thought to myself like ding one of
those moments if my own sister feels
that way with all her credentials I'll
bet I went back to work the next day and
I said hey pull for me all the people
who've left for Parental reasons and or
whatever family reasons and didn't come
back and it began a program of return
ships and I can't tell you how many in
men and women was because they didn't
feel confident to come back they thought
technology passed them by okay we said
it's three months you could stay one
month three months doesn't matter it was
a lot of people like one day they're
like you're right not that much happened
I mean well it happened but I caught up
I actually know more than I think you
know and and I so
with the long answer to your question
about I didn't but I am so empathetic
and I am in awe of what they are able to
do so uh and it made me then I think
more empathetic to the policies and the
like
um around that topic so you could keep
great people in the workforce so you
mentioned your friends with mayabara uh
the the CEO of GM
uh I didn't mean to name drop so don't I
love her she's amazing so I just wanted
to I'm just curious she should do your
your podcast well we'll make it happen a
great leader I I always I tell Mary what
I think of hers I think she's one of the
most authentic leaders out there most
authentic I mean he's just very
different companies huge challenges I
worked there first I remember right so
I'm very you know in some ways I'm very
beholden right you know I'm very
appreciative of what they did I mean
Mary and I are Circa the same well I'm a
bit older so but Circa that genre do
exchange wisdoms oh yeah yeah when you
do anything hard it takes time and
perseverance like we talked about
and you can get that
where do you get the fuel for it you can
either get it from your attitude or you
can get it from your network or your
relationships
and I'm a firm believer relationships
are from what you give not what you get
meaning you give trust me they will come
back at the time they need to come back
to you at these moments in life if you
focus on how can I bring Lex value
there'll be a day I need Lex and he will
be back and so to those women to me
relationships are not transactional
and it's a proof that to this day even
though I'm no longer still active as a
CEO these are all still my friends and
they are we are friends all of us and I
can remember some of them when I first
became a CEO calling me and saying hey
it's a little lonely here so let me talk
to you and then when they became I did
the same for them and then they remember
and they do for the next generation and
so
um it's a very supportive almost to a t
any of the women you could name who have
been CEOs I would say almost to a t have
all been very supportive in fact a
number of us work on a little another
non-for-profit right now called Journey
um which some women who had started the
fortunes most powerful women it started
which was could we get more women
particularly diverse women but women in
general just more quickly be into
positions of leadership and power and so
many of the women you named and more you
know we all dedicate time mentoring
um and kind of creating this little
group of fellows every year to do this
friendship and love is core to this
whole thing not just the success but
just the whole Human Condition let me
ask one last question advice for young
people you've had a difficult upbringing
a difficult life and you've become one
of the most successful human beings in
history what advice would you give to
young people or just people in general
who are struggling a bit trying to
figure out how they can have a career
they can be proud of or maybe a life
they can be proud of
I feel like a life you can be proud of
is just one if you leave something a
little bit better
it doesn't have to be big you know
that's a life well lived right it was
Churchill who said we may it was how you
might remember better than I you make a
living by what you get
and you live a life by what you give
something to that effect
um but my advice would probably when I'm
asked this
I would tell them to ask more questions
and give answers
just just focus on being a sponge and
it's funny I asked my husband the same
question the other day I said hey we're
talking to somebody and people were
asking this and
Easter to pause for a while and he said
I tell him patience
that's what do you mean and he said
I see so many young people like they're
in such a hurry to somewhere I don't
know where and that if they just had
patience and let life unfold
I think they may be surprised where they
ended up
and actually I think that's a really
good answer to be honest along the way
keep asking questions keep that
childlike curiosity I know it sounds so
easy to say it's just so you know
it's yeah like like you said the the
obvious things yeah I think they tend to
be the most profound you're an
incredible human being you're an
inspiration to so many thank you for
helping uh run and uh contribute to one
of the great companies that brings so
much good power to the world and thank
you for putting in the hard work of uh
putting it all in the great book so and
thank you for talking to it this is a
huge honor thank you for doing it you
did a lovely job
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Jeannie rometti to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
Eleanor Roosevelt
do what you feel in your heart to be
right
for you'll be criticized either way
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time